et pour ouvrir ce journal un mot de
politique la primaire à droite aura lieu
en novembre 2016 et les candidats
multiplient les actions et réunion pour
se distinguer que je le rappelle ils
sont douze candidats a déclaré lire
telle au programme de françois fillon
qui étaient expliquées dans la salle
paul gauguin de montigny le bretonneux
l'objet de la rencontre portait sur le
volet sont est une thématique peut
aborder jusqu'à là dans cette primaire
bernard debré ancien ministre actuel
député de paris mais aussi chirurgien
est le porte parole du candidat pour la
santé dont les yvelines la santé en
france
une problématique à laquelle il faut
s'intéresser avant que la situation ne
se dégrade trop selon lui j'écoutais lui
il ya les vrais pompe m et puis des
problèmes d'accessibilité pour les
français et les françaises ont poney ccc
est très claire on sait que choisir un
médecin c'est pas si simple demander un
rendez-vous d'ophtalmologie ça peut
prendre trois mois ou six mois neuf mois
il ya un vrai problème et nous sommes en
train d'essayer de proposer un symptôme
de solutions et nous sommes aussi à
l'écouté des uns des autres parce qu'on
n'a pas la parole le révéler on a
beaucoup travaillé depuis longtemps mais
on est là aussi pour écouter les
questions essayer d'y répondre mais
aussi écouter leurs propositions